it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to the author of the wise men who found
Christmas Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo all right Ray Biden marked a huge
milestone this weekend I understand
he did indeed Joe Biden turned 80 making
him the oldest president in American
history now Lord Democrats are mulling
whether Biden should run in 2024. in the
meantime they're publicly bobbing and
weaving around the question we're just
freezing up
do you hope that President Biden will
run again in 2024 you know I
I I
will have to see you know he's our
president right now he has experience he
has qualifications I won't say if he's
best or if he's not I'll just say this
he has the qualifications to run you
want to see President Biden the senator
run for a second term
well what I want to see right now is
that the Congress of the United States
working with President Biden next year
that's exactly an answer what were those
Sesame Street characters with the split
screen Bernie Sanders the two Muppets
all the Muppets Walmart orphan Stadler
that's it he's one of them definitely it
hearkened back to that that split screen
Laura there's also a Wall Street Journal
a vote cast uh study a poll and they
found that more than half of those were
spawning bought Biden lacked the mental
capacity to serve as president that is
going to Rattle uh his possibilities and
his uh candidacy Raymond that's not fair
no you get sharper with age right
yeah oh sure well Biden today showed why
there are concerns about his age at the
White House he pardoned a pair of
turkeys named Chocolate and Chip not
James and Hunter
nine and a half million turkeys
I tell you what that's like some of the
countries I've been to
in the anyway chocolate is my favorite
chocolate this is my favorite ice cream
so I but I could have we could have
named them chips and science
do you want to talk
maybe my favorite moment Laura you want
to talk to the turkey at that point
given the inflation numbers I thought
maybe the turkey should pardon Biden but
it didn't work out that way he pardoned
both chocolate and Chip or as Biden
called them chocolate chip and chip
oh you know who was really funny is
Trump was really funny with the
pardoning of the turkeys because he's a
natural kind of performer that that was
actually fun but this routine was
well paid a little clock there was
another odd moment when he recognized
his grandchildren Laura that's my
grandson Beau up there and my
granddaughter
don't let him jump
nothing says Happy Thanksgiving like my
grandchildren are about to jump from The
Truman balcony he's used this routine
before
don't jump you look crazy enough to jump
don't
don't jump don't jump and don't jump
from up there okay
why does he say that because these
people are in such Agony they'll
probably take themselves off the roof or
the balconies they could be putting
themselves out of their misery just to
get through another Biden series of
turkey jokes that could be exactly where
we are look the the turkey pardon had
barely happened Lord it was barely
finished when Jill Biden went out to
receive the White House Christmas tree
at this rate New Year's Eve could be
coming tonight at midnight I mean can we
take a breath between the seasons
elections go on for four weeks but
Thanksgiving and Christmas is over in an
afternoon with the bidens I've never
seen anything like it no I mean that's a
quickie but Raymond they had the
Christmas decorations up in like the you
know the pharmacies and stuff they were
up in September like late September
because they have so much inventory yeah
yeah they're always pushing early and
you know look in 2019 the Biden I mean
the trumps also had the turkey pardon
and the Tree revealed on the same day
all right Ray historian the New York
Times is claiming that Justice Alito
leaked the Hobby Lobby decision back in
2014 to a dinner companion only the
supposed source and the Justice insists
the story is totally false right yeah
this New York Times piece was an attempt
to try to blame Alito for the Dobbs
League which makes no sense at all why
would he expose himself to threats and
pressure before Roe was overturned
though I came across a new study that
touches on the cultural impact of the
Dobbs decision it's interesting since
we're always overturned a match.com
study found that one in five couples say
they are more hesitant to have sex four
in five claim they have changed their
dating Behavior since the ruling that's
interesting that kind of reflection I
personally think is a good thing for
people to have and to to consider the
consequences of your actions
particularly when it comes to a life
hanging in the balance like I have a
question was is match.com right up there
with gallop and all the other polling
organizations I mean now they're doing
they commissioned the poll they didn't
do it themselves Laura I got it all
right well happy thanks
yeah happy Raymond Happy Thanksgiving
Eve because you're filling in for me I
understand that's going to be fun uh we
have an All-Star cast just waiting to
fill the Gap there and I'll try to keep
the seat warm Laura awesome all right
Raymond Happy Thanksgiving great to see
you tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else